this morning we're looking at how
increased screen time during the
pandemic is affecting our vision
since this pandemic first hit the
average screen time per person has
spiked
more than 13 hours a day that's a lot
according to eyesafe nielsen
estimates 60 percent of people in one
recent survey say they were worried
about how this will affect their eyes
doctors also say
they're seeing an uptick in vision
issues like dry eye yep i got that
dr christopher starr he was an
ophthalmologist at
weill cornell medical in medicine rather
in new york
joins us with some solutions and whether
he thinks products like blue light
glasses can help
good morning to you doctor good to see
you
hi gail how are you i'm all right with
my dry eye sitting up here but a lot of
people are looking at their screens more
than ever
can you explain why it's such a bad why
it's bad for your eyesight to begin with
yeah it's it's multifactorial we call it
the computer
vision syndrome and it it it combines
both eye strain from just staring at the
computers which are right in front of
you
for all those hours as you said 13 hours
or more
but it also when we're on the computers
when we're staring and fatiguing our
eyes we're also staring and not blinking
as much so the blink rate which is
normally about 16 to 18 times a sec
a minute decreases by about 50 percent
to maybe eight blinks a minute and so
what happens there is the tears
evaporate
and we get these dry spots and the eyes
get drier and drier and redder and more
irritated and gritty as the day goes on
and that leads to fluctuations in vision
and blurred vision and then of course
the eye strain can cause headaches and
all this
so the computer vision syndrome is a
real problem especially
now in the post covid era yeah i never
thought about the lack of blinking what
are the signs of digital eye strain
people listening to you right now are
thinking do i have that
but probably most of us do have it yeah
it's uh you know the the eye strain
component
is is often headaches as the day goes on
frontal headaches pain around the eyes
um the pain behind the eyes and then the
dry eye portion of it is usually
grittiness foreign body sensation the
vision can fluctuate a lot and sometimes
you blink a little bit to clear the
vision and then it gets blurry again
redness and sometimes excessive tearing
burning
all those symptoms are related to this
dryness and the computer
vision syndrome that we're seeing but it
can it can be really hard to take a
break from this
and my daughter's working for home she's
tried blue light glasses
uh with with some help do they generally
work i don't know how much they've done
for her
you know i mean taking breaks is
important and i think that's
the real key here not so much glasses or
filters over your screens taking the
breaks
taking breaks we recommend every 20
minutes or so take a break
look away look into the distance at an
object that's 20 feet away or further
looking at a window is actually perfect
for 20 seconds or more that's what we
used to call the 20 20 20
rule and then i usually add an extra 20
to that the fourth 20 would be during
those breaks
either close your eyes in the you know
sort of zoom era
we can actually close our eyes and not
be judged by our ours
our superiors our bosses you can just
close those eyes on what you're doing
there by closing the eyes
for 20 seconds is to just re
re-lubricate the eyes and get those
tears across the ocular surface
so 20 20 20 20 is very important
the blue light question blue light is
kind of
stimulating and so we usually recommend
blocking blue light
at night when you're trying to go to bed
you want melatonin blue light will block
the melatonin and so
you know ideally no devices in the
bedroom at all but if you're going to
have to look at your phone or your
computer
you should dim the blue lights you don't
need the special glasses
i mean certainly you can use them if you
have them but most of the computers
these days will have
something called a night mode or night
shift mode where you can actually turn
off the blue pixels you know
and so i have mine set to you know nine
o'clock at night
the screen turns yellow and all those
blue pixels disappear
i gotta try that one i don't like that
feature
dr christopher star some very
interesting tips there thank you
we appreciate it